más de 2 millones de muertes por corona
billos en todo el mundo confirmadas por
la organización mundial de la salud casi
400.000 en américa latina pese a ser la
tercera región con más número de muertos
por el momento solo méxico argentina
chile y costa rica iniciaron sus
procesos de vacunación en el resto de
países de la región aún se espera para
dar inicio a este proceso lado ms ya
advirtió el 8 de enero de la desigualdad
patente en la distribución de vacunas a
nivel mundial o vertical
alrededor de 40 países iniciaron ya la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 usando 5
vacunas diferentes sin embargo toda esa
vacunación o prácticamente toda ella se
está realizando en países de ingresos
altos o medios altos como enfatizó
nuestro director general de software en
américa latina esta situación se refleja
de forma clara con respecto a su vecino
eeuu mientras los estadounidenses
vacunaron ya más de 12 millones de
personas en un país de más de 300
millones de habitantes en méxico las
cifras se sitúan más de 400.000
aproximadamente un tercio de la
población de los eeuu el presidente de
lópez obrador apuntó que su país es sin
embargo el que más vacunas tiene en
américa latina gracias a las buenas
relaciones con otros países argentina
por su parte lleva algo más de 200 mil
inyecciones y espera recibir más de 44
millones de dosis a la espera de más
negociaciones chile apenas comenzó a
distribuir las primeras dosis entre la
población de mayor riesgo y los
trabajadores sanitarios si bien tiene
comprometida es 84 millones de dosis la
mayoría de la china sinovac países como
colombia ecuador o panamá tienen
previsto comenzar la vacunación en las
próximas semanas